the e-cigarette giant jeweled labs is
the central focus of a reported
government investigation into marketing
practices that target minors 3 New
Jersey high school students spoke to us
about whether they think the company's
new measures to keep its products away
from teenagers will actually work Jule
you've heard of it before I'm guessing
yeah how common is it in this school
it's hard to tell exactly because kids
can sneak around so much so maybe like
20 percent about I'd say about the same
you think about 20 percent of the kid
sounds about right to you I would say
it's more prevalent among the
underclassmen freshman sophomores and
even eighth graders I would say eighth
graders yes as young Warren Groth
Sebastian Gomez and Greg push are rising
seniors at New Jersey's Sparta high
school they say they don't personally
use e-cigarettes or Jule
but have friends who are addicted what
are the symptoms of addiction other than
just needing it constantly there's this
thing called Nick sick which kids get it
kind of seems like a really bad flu like
just out of nowhere your face goes pale
you start throwing up and stuff and you
just feel horrible to help combat
underaged use Sparta has already cracked
down on students not-so-secret vape
breaks with Hall monitors and a
school-wide system for tracking bathroom
visits now the school will install
sensors in its bathrooms and other
locations that can detect a cigarette
vapor this is what a thousand dollars
per unit School Superintendent Michael
Rossy says when triggered the detectors
will send alerts to school security and
administrators the silent alarm correct
the principal might be 100 yards away
but they would get a note that hey
there's a problem in this in this
bathroom check it out
correct but the students we spoke with
doubt the system will stop their peers
from vaping I think kids just learn to
do it somewhere else
you think kids will beat it it'll just
move them to a different room if they're
knowledgeable of the installation of the
system I think they'll find another
place to Jul which will be helpful for
those of us who actually would like to
utilize the restroom but I don't think
it will curb the use of Joule
you think you'll still be 20% kids this
year yeah because I'll still be able to
do after school on their own time on
Thursday Jul CEO Kevin burns told us
about a new plan to curb youth vaping an
ID verification system that prohibits
cashiers from selling to underage
shoppers and limits the amount customers
can buy we took it'll be a contributor
we think it's a contributor with
reducing reduce and improving access and
reducing the availability of people to
get products do you think that will have
an impact on on how easy it is for kids
to get jewels whatever rules get in
place I think people will always find a
way to get it like they can easily just
ask an older friend or whoever it might
be it'll just create another obstacle
for kids to jump over most of the kids
that I know who do it don't actually use
jewel anymore there's one is called
disposables and you see them right next
to the jewels in the convenience store
you don't have to charge them
it was once they're done you just throw
them out and so it's a hundred percent
not even just a jewel thing if jewel for
some reason goes off the deep end
there's still these other ones that
they're using it's not just you anymore
so what Sebastian is saying there is a
really good point they're using jewel
almost as a generic word they say jewel
will they mean any e-cigarette and if
you go to a convenience store gas
station these days you will see there
are lots and lots of brands the FDA
didn't even start regulating this until
2016 there are very few rules in place
it is long overdue for someone to step
in set standards take some products off
the shelf maybe let others stay it's
interesting they said as young as eighth
grade I was wondering here that one in
twenty middle schoolers use e-cigarettes
in each month we also asked the students
by the way if they knew any adults who
had used an e-cigarette to quit smoking
they couldn't name any but the teachers
could so there is a divide here they see
the problem among their peer group some
of the teachers are aware of yeah they
have a family member who quit a
cigarette traditional cigarettes with an
e-cigarette you know they say if they
have those detection devices in the
bathroom they'll still find other ways
and the same thing about the ID
verification in the stores but I have to
think that if it gets harder and harder
to duel but they're gonna do it less
yeah yeah I mean yes it should work we
were all children once we all know how
to get around yeah yeah so not a good
thing just our resources yes there are
sorts well not a good thing